[Musique]
david rigoulet roze bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin dans la matinale de
rtl france reprise aujourd'hui un donc
des pourparlers à doha entre les
représentants du gouvernement afghan et
des talibans la question d'un cessez le
feu du partage du pouvoir sera donc au
coeur des échanges alors est ce qu'on
peut espérer des avancées cette fois
c'est vrai que le il y avait une
suspension qu'elle était décidée le 2
décembre dernier
donc laissons des négociations
laborieuses elles sont
c'était un veau un des volets qui était
prévu par l'accord signé entre les
américains et talibans lundi 9 février à
dos 1
c'était le effectivement des
négociations un travail gagnent qui sont
laborieuses parce qu'il ya il ya des
obstacles récurrents qui ont été
soulevées notamment la libération
prisonniers à certains obstacles ont été
levés mais donc qu'il y avait
effectivement des divergences
d'appréciation et le 2 décembre
les deux parties sont entendus pour
faire une suspension en signant un
accord de trois pages sur les procédures
les règles et procédures à suivre pour
les négociations futures et avec la mise
en place d'un comité travaille sur
l'ordre du jour qui sera abordé
effectivement partie à partir du 5
janvier la question évidemment qui qui
traversent toujours ce type de
glaciation en l'occurrence c'est le la
question du cessez le feu la
pérennisation d'un cessez-le-feu puisque
si les troupes américaines ne font plus
l'objet d'attaqués évidemment compte
tenu de l'accord qui a été signé en
revanche les troupes gouvernementales
elles sont soumises à des attaques
récurrentes et d'ailleurs le chef du
service de l'enseignement a évoqué près
de 18000 attaquante les forces
gouvernementales l'année dernière donc
c'est dire que la situation évidemment
est loin d'être pacifiée
oui vous vous rappelez un contexte très
tendu en afghanistan on a du mal à
imaginer que les discussions puissent
être possible dans ce contexte elles
sont de toute façon
ardu c'est inévitable notamment il ya
c'est ce qui a fait l'objet dès hier la
suspension
il ya la question de la nature du régime
qui sera éventuellement mis en place
dans le cadre d'une transition politique
le caractère islamique notamment et donc
d'où les divergences d'interprétation
effectivement sur la religion 10 dit de
manière fait féministe féminisé c'est un
enjeu considérable parce que les
talibans évidemment n'ont pas changé
leur leur perception du régime politique
qui semble qu'ils entendent voir se
mettre en place
après le retrait des américains un
retrait qui qui est normalement effectif
à partir d'une totale qui est effectif à
partir du 1er mai prochain
mais il ya déjà un retraité très
largement entamée puisque 17 novembre
dernier christopher miller nouveau
secrétaire d'état à la défense avait
annoncé que à compter du 15 janvier il
ne resterait plus que 2500 soldats
américains ça veut dire que pour la
première fois depuis 2002 les troupes
occidentales su présente sur le sur le
sol afghan dans le cadre de l'opération
résolu supporte sont majoritairement le
nom d' american donc c'est effectivement
un tournoi qui pose du problème d' un
problème d'ailleurs aux alliés des
etats-unis dans la collection justement
effectivement un retrait qui inquiète
tant certains pays de l'otan de l'union
européenne ils ont peur de laisser le
champ libre aux terroristes alors ce qui
n'est pas le cas de
des talibans regardez l'avis du
porte-parole des talibans c'est une
bonne avancée et c'est dans l'intérêt
des peuples afghans et américains au
plus tôt les troupes étrangères s'en
iront au plus vite la guerre finira
alors effectivement est ce que une fois
que les soldats américains seront partis
d'afghanistan est ce que on peut espérer
davantage de paix comme semble
l'affirmer les talibans bah il ya une
vraie prudence qui est de mise
y compris à l'onu d'ailleurs parce que
le débat aura lie en ski et la
représentant spécial pract des
négociations avec beaucoup de
circonspection
elle rappelle d'ailleurs que six
journalistes et de défenseurs des droits
de l'homme ont été tuées en 2020 que la
situation est quand même délétère et que
effectivement la question d'un retrait
précipité pose problème
il a été évoqué d'ailleurs par gestes
total merde le le le secrétaire général
de l'otan que l'on dit a évidemment très
américain pro américain mais en tout cas
il a il a évoqué le fait qu' il y avait
un danger sur un retrait précipité et
même aux états unis d'ailleurs il ya
certaines voix qui ont qui ont évoqué le
fait que c'était un retrait accéléré
était une mauvaise idée
y compris dans le camp donald trump
d'ailleurs mais ça ne va pas remettre en
cause effectivement la décision du
président américain puisque c'était une
de ses promesses de campagne et on peut
penser que la future administration by
donne ne reviendra pas d'ailleurs sur ce
retrait c'est plutôt sur le calendrier
et les modalités mais en tout cas sur le
principe le principe du retrait est acté
ben justement l'arrivée de
l'administration bailon au pouvoir aux
états unis à ce qu'elle peut faire
évoluer les pourparlers en tout cas
avoir un impact sur sur ces pourparlers
qui
on débute aujourd'hui elle reprendra le
la ligne qui a été les qualités danse et
de toute façon le président futur
président en exercice joe biden n'a
jamais été pour une présence permanente
et il y prend acte aussi de on va dire
de la lassitude de l'opinion américaine
donc il y aura pas de remise en cause du
retrait mais il y aura certainement des
ajustements ponctuels ans en fonction de
la situation sur le terrain pour ne pas
donner l'impression aussi aux alliés
puisqu'il ya un souhait de rapprochement
avec les alliés de l'otan de la part du
président biden qui veut revenir sur
certaines pratiques un peu brutale de
son prédécesseur donc il y aura la prise
en compte un peu plus importante
effectivement des inquiétudes des
partenaires de la coalition sur place
mais le principe lui même du retrait est
finalisé merci beaucoup à vous david
rigoulet roze l'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin en direct sur rtl
france je le rappelle vous êtes
chercheur à l'ifas chercheur associé à
l'iris et rédacteur en chef de la revue
orient stratégique